foreign
I was thinking about the places that I
personally have adjusted my
understanding in some cases radically in
some cases it has actually flipped it's
reversed
and it's a never-ending stream I spent a
couple minutes just thinking this
morning about places where I had uh
changed what I understood
and in fact I realized that
one of our first forays into this I made
a substantial error with respect to my
understanding of the science
the actual science which was I believed
that because we were dealing with an RNA
virus that it transcribed itself into
DNA it reverse transcribed itself and
installed itself in the genome which
turns out is not true for coronaviruses
so just to use one of the pieces of
jargon that many people will be familiar
with
um you thought and you said on stream as
I remember it um that because it was an
RNA virus it was a retrovirus yeah and
not true not how they work so okay
embarrassing error for me right away but
immediately figured it out and corrected
it right exactly all right
I don't know how long I could go listing
all of the places where I changed my
understanding many of them maybe all of
them I think uh you share but
nonetheless I realized my position on
the functionality of hydroxychloroquine
completely inverted I believed which we
never talked about on air because it
just it just didn't even hit Radar
really this was actually my my biggest
embarrassment I do not have a good
explanation for how I missed the fact
that I was being misled by Propaganda on
this very useful drug until
embarrassingly late but anyway that one
was remarkably that one got us both in a
way that most of the you know things
like two weeks to flatten the curve like
a lot of things that a lot of people
accepted like we know we never believed
but somehow the
it's a it's a trump delusion and it's
hydroxychloric when
and there was a flood of information and
all this but yeah I I bought that yep I
bought it for a long time yeah too long
yeah and it's not true all right uh
Ivermectin effectiveness
um now mind you effectiveness on two
different fronts both as a treatment for
covid and as a prophylactic my position
on this has changed it has changed
slightly because one paper that appeared
to demonstrate extreme Effectiveness did
not turn out to be what it appeared to
be on first pass I still think the
experiment took place it gave a
compelling result but because the method
section
did not provide enough information and
the data set when I requested it was not
forthcoming is the one out of Argentina
yeah okay the this the carvio study the
experiment is not reproducible and so I
said
you have to take this piece of evidence
and give it zero evidentiary weight
because it is essential for science to
be repeatable
now I would make that criticism of many
experiments on the other side now too
but but didn't the Laurie uh the
meta-analysis remove it and get very
much the same results that was a
different study okay yeah so because it
was not a randomized controlled trial it
wasn't in there in the first place it's
a different study but yes and you know I
had tests on because I wanted people to
understand that the fact that you've got
a study that turns out to be fraudulent
does not invalidate a meta-analysis that
included it in fact this is one of the
strengths of meta-analysis is that you
can simply say what happens if we
exclude this study what does it do to
the result and the answer was it didn't
change it very much but my position on
Ivermectin Effectiveness has largely
changed because I remectin Effectiveness
has largely changed because the virus
changed because the virus is is mutating
as viruses will do
especially with a strong selective Force
well strong selective Force now this one
perplexed me you know at first I thought
is it reduced in Effectiveness with
respect to the later variance because
um because resistance has evolved which
I initially said I didn't think was
going to happen yeah and
um apparently that is not what's going
on what's going on I feel like what
little I understand about Ivermectin
mechanism of action it wouldn't be
resistance resistance is unlikely
because there are multiple mechanisms of
action and so the point is progress
against one doesn't substantially alter
the fate of the virus in its context and
it's such a broad spectrum
anti-parasitic right right so what
apparently my understanding I think
largely from Garrett vandenbosch is that
what happened is the virus adopted a
different strategy in which It produced
many many more copies and so you had to
drive the effective dose of ivermectin
way up which then creates side effects
which are not terrible side effects but
nonetheless you don't want to be using
this as a prophylactic at a dose that
it's causing like visual side effects
and things like it's not like you don't
become a quadruped and start asking for
a saddle no that never happened that was
the FDA spreading incidentally asterisk
for later I know we're on a roll here
but um the fda's lawyers made some
interesting claims in court recently
about what they did and did not say
about Ivermectin yes apparently we've
got them telling us that uh it was just
a recommendation yes just a
recommendation but anyway okay so my
position on Iram active Effectiveness
has changed a little bit because my
understanding of the evidence changed
but also because I remarked an
Effectiveness change and the point is a
model that is updating with evidence
then takes on the clinical change and
the effectiveness of this drug and
incorporates it the model that is static
that stuff doesn't work at all remains
static
um great well
the virus is evolving right like so so
even even a conclusion that is 100 right
at time a at time B may not be uh
precisely because the object in question
that you were talking about efficacy
against her for or whatever uh has
changed and therefore so should the
interaction with it right so so should
you expect the interaction with it too
so the point is a dynamic model is
inherently better for two different
reasons one it gets better with respect
to a static set of facts and two it's
the only game in town with respect to a
changing set of facts right and I don't
mean changing as in we know the facts to
be different but changing because
something is rapidly evolving for
example and therefore changing the
utility yeah
um
the next one on my list is mask
Effectiveness we were famously early or
I was particularly aggressive on the
potential utility of masks and them
especially the mask that I was
suggesting people use which was
practical because it wasn't such an
impediment to life turned out to be
essentially useless
um the cloth mask and 95 is better still
not effective but uh you know may have
some impact
vaccine Effectiveness I was quite
convinced by the initial propaganda it
now seems that came out of the trials
that were used to sell the vaccines to
us that the vaccines were likely to be
important in the control of the disease
we now know that they do not have even
the most basic characteristics that
would be necessary for them to be useful
in this regard but I was initially taken
in by the propaganda my position has
changed vaccine safety I was always
alarmed that these things couldn't
possibly be safe in the way they were
saying because safety doesn't mean
harmless safety means riskless and there
was an obvious long list of potential
risks that couldn't be eliminated at the
point these things emerged so I still
can't be still can't be but the point is
I was actually too cautious turns out
you know I was worried
that 20 years down the road we were
going to discover a longevity difference
between people who had taken these
things or some slow pattern of tumors or
autoimmunity would emerge wow did that
safety signal show up fast
um so anyway my position has moved in
the direction of wow these things not
only are they unsafe by virtue of being
risky but they appear to be doing a huge
amount of harm at the same time they're
not very effective at doing the one
thing that was of primary interest which
was controlling the spread of the virus
um
uh
coveted origin I initially had a chart
that uh go ahead uh I'm just I'm
reminded with that last one so um so far
you know I think we so far basically we
had the same same positioning on on
almost all these things
um
the thing uh that was used to dismiss
those of us who were concerned about
code vaccine safety and efficacy early
on
was that we were inherently the same
people who minimized the risks of covet
itself
and uh actually so our friend Holly has
written a piece called
such a brilliant title the end of Faith
Harris in Sam Harris
and she actually she does she does right
by us and discusses
um you know his claim that we're those
people and says I I know they're not you
can just look at Dark Horse and see how
seriously they were taking covet but
also I Holly know they're not because I
had kova twice and here's how they
behaved towards me
so uh the thing
that I guess I want to add then to your
messaging here is
um the ways that people are dismissed
gets lumped into like you know oh if
you're a then you're a plus b it's like
but uh but I'm not and the fact that you
can't see that it's possible to be a not
b suggests again that you've been handed
a bill of goods that you've adopted a
model that you didn't think through that
you just accepted it right that the only
way
to be have concern about the safety of
the brand new to Human Experience
coveted vaccines was to also be a
coveted minimizer
is an absurd position and the fact is
actually that I think another place that
I at least
um
uh have have changed my positioning over
time in the almost three years is at
first we're like oh God you know what is
this no it's not the flu it's different
it seems to be worse not clear no it's
definitely not a cold
but the fact again is that not only do
we have more information now but we also
have a change in the disease itself now
long covet is is real and dangerous and
unfortunately at this point it's also
true that because both uh SARS Kobe 2
and the MRNA vaccines are using the
spike protein as the thing that uh well
SARS Kobe 2 isn't using the spike
protein but that is present in both of
them and it's because that is the source
of so much of the cytotoxicity uh it's
it's hard in many cases to tell the
difference between you know oh do you
have long covet are you vaccine injured
right it can it can it is at least
potentially hard to tell right it's a
confound it's
it's potentially hard to tell
but
it does seem that if you
don't
for whatever reason
your genetics your lack of comorbidity
is your ability to treat early with all
the things that we know you can treat
early with have a mild case of covet and
don't have lingering effects
it doesn't have to be a big deal except
that we still don't know what the
long-term effects very long-term effects
might be yep
um I would say that there's a big
lurking question to the extent that
people are trying to apply uh what we're
talking about you know okay how am I not
going to be on the wrong side of this
how am I going to build an active model
that gets better over time especially if
you're not somebody trained in a
relevant field well part of the trick is
figuring out how to proxy
trust and revoke it if somebody doesn't
do this job very well yeah but I would
say one question that remains very
active in my mind
is what are the chances that if we
hadn't deployed the vaccines
we'd be done
but this would legitimately have burned
itself out and while that will sound
fanciful can you be you're saying it
would not have become endemic I am
saying that because let me point
something out Wuhan one it's gone it's
extinct and so the question is did herd
immunity Drive Wuhan one to extinct I've
never heard that term before I can
extrapolate what you mean move on one
you're you're busy with a it's not wild
type but like you know if if sarsko V2
hadn't been Frank engineered in a in a
lab it would be the wild type the
original virus that uh that we were all
dealing with in spring 2020. right so
that thing is and you know I will say
that there is a complex set of questions
around viral swarms which I think are
not well dealt with and need to be
understood but one very live possibility
according to my model and who knows next
week I may understand why my model is
wrong and therefore this line of inquiry
doesn't make sense the one very live
possibility
is that if we had done nothing that
drove the evolution of these uh these
viruses that we would be done by virtue
of herd immunity which would have been
painfully acquired with many many deaths
but nonetheless we'd be finished and
that the they're finished with the virus
not finished as Humanity right finished
with the virus covid would have burned
itself out right
um we'll never know I don't know that
we'll never know I think we will never
know for sure
I think the point is this is a tractable
question this is a studyable question
and what we have done by deploying a
cartoonishly narrow vaccine is we have
Amplified The evolutionary signal we
have asked
the we have asked Evolution to play a
game that it is master of right not only
can you adapt but can you adapt to
something stupidly narrow of course you
can right easily and again and again so
um
so in any case this is a place where and
I'm going to argue that the the right
way to think about these complex
problems is to get over your instinct to
LEAP to a conclusion to LEAP to a
conclusion of any kind really right the
point is you should maintain these
things probabilistically
and yeah the tough for people right so
tough for people but because people want
certainty
this I know well so that that is true it
is true some people want but you know I
used to I used to play this game with
our kids where if they said something
with certainty I used to say what do you
think the probability is that that's not
true and of course how certain are you
for very young children the answer 100
100 of course and the answer is no you
just screwed up you just told me
something wrong yeah the probability
should not be zero it might be a tiny
fraction of one percent
right the tiny fraction but and you know
I mean let's um very young children you
expect that answer and yeah of course
but the point is you got to break that
habit right you got to break that habit
and what we have and you did that is an
adult expert class that we are now
detecting never got that lesson right
they and so what this does is it creates
a very bad mechanism for thinking that
is cryptic in any place where your
intellectual ancestors have done a
decent job right so the point is if you
walk into physics right and you adopt
the standard model the standard model is
pretty good it's pretty predictive and
you can become expert at it but you're
not going to extend it if what you're
doing is taking on that model and using
it as a set of assumptions which is fair
but if that's all you do then the point
is you can't detect where this thing
doesn't work right right you're just
going to keep applying it and you're
going to you're going to rationalize it
[Music]